KNOW I'M HERE PORTANTINO HERE
BATES BRADFORD. OFFERED HERE
THERE ALSO THEY'RE ALSO HERE
HELL HELLO HERE JONES Y. CASKEY
CASKEY HERE. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE WE HAVE TEN BILLS TO
HEAR TODAY ALL OF WHICH ARE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES AND ALL OF
THE AUTHORS HAVE WAIVED
PRESENTATION SO THEY SHOULD BE
A RELATIVELY QUICK HEARING
THERE ARE TWO BILLS ON FILE
THAT WE WILL NOT BE HEARING
TODAY SB SIX SIX ZERO FROM MR
LEVINE IS A TO YOUR BILL NOW AT
THE AUTHOR'S REQUEST AND AB FOR
THIRTY GALLAGHER WILL BE
REPORTED DIRECTLY TO THE SENATE
FOR IS A TWENTY EIGHT POINT
EIGHT. AS REMINDER WHEN YOU DO
COME UP IN TESTIMONY TESTIFY.
PLEASE CONFINE YOUR COMMENTS TO
THE FISCAL IS IMPACTS OF THE
BILL. AND WE SORT OF REFER WANT
TO REFRAIN FROM LENGTHY POLICY
DISCUSSIONS SO. OUR FIRST BILL
IS AB TEN BY MR CHU ON TAX
CREDITS FOR LOW INCOME HOUSING
IS THERE ANY SUPPORT. IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION IS THERE FILE
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TULI ON AIR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL
THIS TIME BUT WE KNOW THAT IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
AND A AND FUTURE YEARS THIS
BILL COULD EVENTUALLY LEAD TO
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT REVENUE
LOSSES. A TO THE EXTENT THAT
CREDIT ALLOCATIONS ARE MADE
THAT OTHERWISE WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN DUE TO THE EXISTING
REQUIREMENT FOR BUDGET
APPROPRIATION THAT IS BEING
REMOVED UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL. ADDITIONALLY THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD DOES NOT
ANTICIPATE ANY IMPACT RESULTING
FROM THIS MEASURE. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
BY MISTER GARCIA ON. THIS
MATTER. I'M SORRY MISS GARCIA.
ON MATTRESS RECOVERY AND
RECYCLING IS THERE ANY SUPPORT
IN FAVOR OF ONE EIGHTY SEVEN.
SIR ANY OPPOSITION. HER FOR
HELP YES WERE NEUTRAL ON THIS
MEASURE THE DEPARTMENT OF
RESOURCES RECYCLING IN RECOVERY
ESTIMATES ON GOING COSTS OF
SEVENTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
THESE COSTS WOULD BE REIMBURSED
BY THE MATTRESS RECYCLING
ORGANIZATION. THAT THROUGH THE
USE MATTRESS RECYCLING FUND.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB THREE
NINETY FOUR BY MR OBERNOLTE. ON
SEQUEL IS THEIR SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING KELLY GATHERED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT. IS THERE
OPPOSITION. IS THERE A FIVE YES
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
HAS A WILL RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
PROVIDE ESTIMATED COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE MOST RECENT
VERSION OF THIS MEASURE.
HOWEVER THE DEPARTMENT DID
INDICATE FOR THE PRIOR VERSION
OF THIS BILL WHICH WE WOULD
NOTICE A POTENTIALLY SIMILAR
AND WOULD IMPOSE A COMPATIBLE
WORKLOAD WOULD HAVE RESULTED IN
TOTAL COST OF ONE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. AND ONE POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING.
SHE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THREE NINETY FOUR.
WE'LL GO TO SPENCE A. B. SIX
NINETY FOUR. MEASURE WHEN ON
VETERAN HOUSING AND HOMELESS
PREVENTION IS THEIR SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION SIR FILE. YES WE
WOULD KNOW THAT IF THIS
MEASURES APPROVED BY THE VOTERS
OF THE STATE WOULD BE
AUTHORIZED ISSUE SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL
OBLIGATION BONDS ASSUMING A
THIRTY YEAR REPAYMENT PERIOD
FOR THESE BONDS AND AN INTEREST
RATE OF 5% OF THE BOND WOULD
REQUIRE APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
SIX POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
IN ANNUAL DEBT SERVICE AT A
COST OF IN TOTAL OF ONE POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLARS. WOULD KNOW
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT INDICATES
ADDITIONAL WORK TO ADMINISTER
THIS WOULD BE THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE FIRST
YEAR AND TWO POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING LASTLY
I WOULD NOTE THAT THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS A STILL
OUTSTANDING ON THE ORIGINAL SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR BOND
ISSUED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIX NINETY FOUR
WE'RE GONNA SUSPENSE. AB TEN
TWENTY SEVEN BY MS BURKE ON
CALIFORNIA CON COMPETES TAX
CREDIT THEIR SUPPORT. SIR
OPPOSITION MR FILE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ESTIMATES SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL STAFF AND FUNDS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS MEASURE.
DUE TO THE UNPRECEDENTED NATURE
OF THIS BILL AN ESTIMATE WAS
NOT PROVIDED HOWEVER WE WOULD
NOTE THAT THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS WOULD LIKELY BE
SIGNIFICANT AND WELL OVER ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY. SHE
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
A. B. TEN TWENTY SEVEN WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE AB TEN EIGHTY AND
MS GONZALEZ ON PLASTIC
POLLUTION AB TEN EIGHTY. YOUR
SUPPORT. OPPOSITION FILE. CAL
RECYCLE ESTIMATES COST
APPROXIMATELY SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS INITIALLY AND
SIX POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
ON GOING FROM THE INTEGRATED
WASTE MANAGEMENT ACCOUNT A TO
DEVELOP THE SKIPPING PLAN
ADOPTED IMPLEMENT REGULATIONS
AND DEVELOP A MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
FOR SINGLE USE PACKAGING AND
PRIORITY SINGLE USE PLASTIC
PRODUCTS A CAL RECYCLE ALSO
ESTIMATES A SIXTEEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
COSTS OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD
FOR CONTRACTS TO DEVELOP THE
DATABASE SYSTEMS. THE TRACK AND
STORE THE PRODUCT INFORMATION.
AS WELL AS AN ADDITIONAL ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING FOR
DATABASE SERVICE AND SUPPORT.
ADDITIONALLY CAL RECYCLE IS NOT
ABLE TO PROVIDE ACOSTA MESS
CAUGHT AT COST ESTIMATE AT THE
TIME OF THIS ANALYSIS FOR THE
ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS INCLUDED
IN THE LATEST VERSION OF THE
BILL. HOWEVER WE WOULD NOTE
THAT THOSE COSTS WILL LIKELY BE
SIGNIFICANT. SING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TEN EIGHTY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE A. B. TO ME
A CA FOURTEEN MS GONZALEZ IS
THEIR SUPPORT. THEIR OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JASON MURPHY ON BEHALF
OF THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
HERE TODAY IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AC FOURTEEN AS DOING THE
ANALYSIS UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
ESTIMATES FISCAL ESTIMATE
FISCAL COSTS THE RECEIVER BOX
ME ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS THESE
COSTS ARE ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE
ADDITIONAL WAGE AND BENEFITS
PREMIUMS AT UNIVERSITY WOULD
HAVE TO COVER IF WE WERE TO
NEED TO BRING THE CONTRACT
WORKED OVER CURRENTLY DESCRIBED
PERFORMED WITH VENDORS AND
CONTACTS STAFF IN HOUSE I WOULD
JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THERE'S BEEN A
CRITIQUE OF THE UNIVERSITIES.
FISCAL ESTIMATES HAS BEEN
CIRCULATING BUT FROM THE
SPONSORS PERSPECTIVE THE LAST
WEEK OR SO THE BELIEVES THAT WE
COULD ABSORB THAT ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO MILLION DOLLAR
FISCAL ESTIMATE WITHIN THE
EXISTING CONTRACTS SPEND THE
DAY BELIEVE THE TROUBLE TO
OVERHEAD AND PROFIT SO TO SPEAK
TO THE VENDORS NOW JUST POINT
OUT. WE STRONGLY DISAGREE WITH
THAT CONTENTION IN FACT THE
CASE IS THAT SO MANY OF OUR
CONTRACTS FOR SERVICES AND SO
FORTH INCLUDE A VARIETY OF NON
WAGE COMPONENTS INCLUDING.
MATERIALS SUPPLIES INSURANCE.
AND THE LIKE AND IF THERE WERE
TO BE DISCONTINUATION A
PROHIBITION ON UNIVERSITIES
CONTRACTING WE HAVE TO BRING
ALL OF THOSE. SIMILAR COSTS IN
HOUSE SO THERE SEEMS TO BE NO
SAVINGS FROM DISCONTINUATION
SERVICES ONLY THOSE ADDITIONAL
WAGE AND BENEFIT PREMIUMS ARE
DESCRIBED EARLIER THANK YOU
REMAIN OPPOSED. BARBARA GLAZER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WE TOO ARE OPPOSED
FOR THE REASONS STATED THANK
YOU. SIR FIVE YES WE ARE ALSO
IN OPPOSITION BECAUSE IT
RESTRICTS THE ABILITY OF THE UC
BOARD OF REGENTS WHICH IS
CHARGED WITH GOVERNING THE
UNIVERSITY TO DETERMINE THE
MOST APPROPRIATE WAYS TO MANAGE
THEIR OPERATIONS CONSISTENT
WITH STICKLES. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION A
CA FOURTEEN WE'RE GONNA
SUSPENSE. AB FOURTEEN FORTY TWO
THREE OF US SHARE OUR VALUES
TAX CREDIT SIR SUPPORT. SIR
OPPOSITION. SIR FILE YES THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD ESTIMATES
GENERAL FUND REVENUE LOSSES OF
NINE MILLION DOLLARS BEGINNING
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
WE KNOW THAT THE REVENUE LOSSES
CAN BE EXPECTED TO INCREASE
FURTHER IN SUBSEQUENT YEARS AND
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD STATES
THAT THIS BILL WOULD NOT
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
DEMAND IT'S ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS. A LESLIE AS OF THE DATE
OF THIS ANALYSIS THE CALIFORNIA
FILM COMMISSIONS ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS HAD NOT YET BEEN
DETERMINED. SHE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION A. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE MISTER GRAYSON ON HOUSING
DATA. SIR SUPPORT. HAVE A GOOD
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT. MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS LOSE BRONTE WITH
CALIFORNIA BE IN SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION SHARE FILE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES
GENERAL FUND COSTS OF SIX POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
FIRST YEAR APPROXIMATELY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES ESTIMATES SIX
HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME AND NINE
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING TO ESTABLISH
THE STATE APACE SHOULD EACH CD
DESIGNATE TGS AS THE STATE
ENTITY TO CREATE. AND MAINTAIN
IT. SEE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AND
THEN OUR FINAL BILL. AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE. BY
MISTER RIVAS ON H. TO A WORKER
HOUSING IS OUR SUPPORT. MORNING
LOWS MONDAY WITH CALIFORNIA BE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR
OPPOSITION. IS THERE FILE YES
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE THE RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT. THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES
GENERAL FUND COSTS OF NINE
POINT NINE MILLION IN THE FIRST
YEAR AND NINE MILLION DOLLARS
ON GOING FOR ADDITIONAL STAFF.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ALSO
ESTIMATES ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
ENHANCEMENTS AND ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
ANNUALLY FOR MAINTENANCE AND
UPGRADES TO THIS DATABASE. THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD HAD YET TO PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ANALYSIS BASED ON THE
MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS. BUT WE
DO KNOW THERE MAY BE ADDITIONAL
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
TURNING DRINKING WATER SAFETY
FOR AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYEE
HOUSING. THANK YOU SEE NO
QUESTIONS OR OBJECTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
WHICH CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS ON
THE DAY. SURE